i'll start recording
we're good thank you as chair of the
house ways and means committee i find
that due to the state of the emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
covert 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to me
electronically
this is a executive session on senate
bills
under the ways and means committee
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporariously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order and confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporariously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
the public has access to contemporaries
listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available on
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website
the notice for this meeting complies the
house rules
rsa91a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call
271 3600 or email
hcs life.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned
and rescheduled i want to introduce the
staff that are on the
meeting assisting us jennifer fuller the
committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call
vote let's start the meeting by taking
roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting
which is required under the right to
know law representative bernstein
you'll call the role and identify those
that have
been replaced by some members that are
normally here
thank you thank you mr chair and good
morning to you and good morning to
everyone
it is may 11 2021 it's 9
30 4 a.m we'll begin roll call with
representative patrick
browning yes i'm here in my home in
stratham
and my wife is in the house sitting in
for mary griffin we're very happy to
have representative don johnson
good evening good morning yes morning
thank you i am here alone
and i will be keeping my um
mike on you i have two barking dogs
good morning and it's great to have you
with us dawn thank you for having me i
appreciate it
representative hollery uh home in hudson
the wife is in the house that's it
representative ober
oman hudson five cats indoors one
outside catchings of rays
nice representative doucette good
morning mr clerk i'm joining you from
jupiter florida this morning there are
some workers on the property
and it doesn't stink
good morning uh your clerk is
representative bursting i'm in my home
office in nottingham new hampshire
representative robert elliott i'm at
my daughter's house in salem new
hampshire there's no one else here
sitting in for representative canigion
is representative tony pimanti
you're muted representative
representative vermonte you're muted
sorry about that i'm here in sandown uh
in my home uh
and i'm by myself good morning and thank
you for joining us
representative herschel nunes good
morning mr clerk i am home alone in
hellham new hampshire
good morning we're sitting in for
representative tim baxter we are very
happy to have representative maureen
mooney with us
thank you good morning i'm here in
merrimack at my home
alone representative spillsbury
good morning home alum in charlestown
representative tutor good morning home
alone in northwood
representative army good morning
home alone in lebanon representative
ames
i'm here in my home office in jeffrey
alone
representative southward here in dover
representative malloy
uh representative thomas c
schamberg good morning representative
bergstein
i'm here in wilmette in my office my
wife's in her office and we have the
blue skies like your background here
thank you
representative edith tucker i'm here
in randolph alone representative camarlo
i'm in swansea alone representative
laughman
good morning visiting family in
somerville mass but i am alone this
morning
good morning representative gorg good
i am present and alone representative
hacken phillips
good morning i am also present and alone
representative james murphy good morning
i am here alone in hanover
and by chairman representative norman
major
representative major good morning i'm in
my home office in plasto
and my wife is in the house mr chair
there are 23 members present
oh i just saw representative malloy
actually we got a full house today
uh let's just ask mr representative
malloy to
get invited yes i am here uh
in greenland uh alone uh sorry for uh
being a few minutes late
i just uh some other things going on
thank you as long as you don't blame
traffic
no traffic no traffic to me mr chair
there are 24 members present
thank you representative bernstein
representative
thank you mr chairman i'd like to ask
for
a democratic caucus for
probably 10 minutes i don't know how
long it'll take us to get
where we're going so it might be 15.
try to keep it to 10 minutes we
certainly appreciate that
um you can have your democratic caucus
thank you on amanda do we um
can we use your of course i'll send it
back out
great thank you bye so we will take a
break for
10 minutes
it is now 9 39 so we come back at 9
50.
okay
oh
um
administration
somebody has an open mic
okay
you
this
should we just get started without them
they'll be coming along are they talking
about
22 and 27 is that is that a good
assumption norm
uh yes
hey uh alan one of my bills got passed
because they didn't show up so
mr chair it looks like representative uh
jerry stringham has his hand up
well he might have just put it down
he did a moment ago
no yes it is you probably want to say
hello
um you want to let jerry string him in
jenny
i just promoted him there he is handsome
guy
morning jerry uh once we
um go into executive session and we'll
have to
hey good morning just on behalf of all
the all the democrats that are often
meeting in the other room i
i think we should wait that's all i
would just i i just thought i'd
would speak on behalf of the poor
minority here while
while you're all having fun at our
at our absence it's good you have that
it's good you're advocating for them
representative it's nice to see you all
and uh
enjoy listen i'll enjoy listening to
your debate
jerry you used the wrong adjective there
you said the poor
democrats it's poor republicans get that
well always good to hear from you jerry
gary where where are you these days you
home
uh actually today i'm in maryland and uh
i'll be
i'll be back in new hampshire tomorrow
you guys know
but uh i've been traveling for a while
but thanks for asking
have a crab cake for me
backpack my brother said to say hello to
you if i uh
thanks i said hi
i went to his brother's wedding years
and years ago
i didn't know jerry i knew it was
i knew his brother through to my wife
and uh
then jerry made the connection last year
that we did that i knew his brother i
didn't i didn't make the connection that
stringham was the same string
so it's a small world
yeah looks like our colleagues are
coming back on
okay we'll have to uh apologize it took
a little bit longer than that
including to figure out how to get
herself
okay
and um
gary's back in the attendees right
i'm trying to figure that out
how did we get in here i did it
alan oh thank you you're welcome
all right now we can go
into exact executive session
and the calendar
says start to senate bill 3.
we'll discuss senate bill 3 at the end
and we'll start with senate bill 22
and with senate bill 22-fn and act
relative to the sale of lucky seven
tickets
uh representative doucet
good morning mr chairman i move ought to
pass on senate bill 22.
representative moves out to pass on
senate bill
22 and we have a second
bursting with second
that was that was actually
representative bursting who seconded mr
chairman
oh oh okay i thought he said hursting
first oh forget it forget it
thank you
representative decided you want to speak
the emotion certainly mr chairman uh
senate bill 22 uh in a nutshell there
are two specifics that it addresses it's
a
deal size for the lucky seven tickets
and it allows for
a deal size of uh up to 14 000
and also uh allows for
uh 50 cent one dollar and
again 25 cent denominations for lucky
seven tickets
let me throw the discussion on senate
bill 22.
brothers uh representative ames
thank you um during our
review of this bill there was some um
reference to changing the
language that's in this bill regarding
25 cent tickets
to make it instead of a mandatory
provision that
charitable organizations shall also
offer 25
cent tickets 25 cent and 50 cent tickets
to make the 25 cent part of the
an option for the organizations and
my sense was that uh that
many members of the committee thought
that was a good idea so i
my question is what's become of that or
why
why not take the time to make that
amendment if there is that kind of
support for that
representative
yeah thank you representative i
remember the conversation but nobody
came uh to the forefront with
with the uh with the amendment and uh
i know at least my position um
is that just just these changes are
minimal changes in will be beneficial to
the
charitable organizations as written
any any further discussion on senate
bill 22.
mr chair representative thank you
i did produce such an amendment because
uh the charities under our current law
by mistake
are required to buy the 25 cent tickets
even though
they aren't going to use them and this
was brought forward to us
by someone who does represent the paper
tickets
on but i put that in an amendment which
also got rid of
sections one and two because i fervently
believe
that this kind of thing ought to be done
by the commission
and because since i've been around this
long i know that the legislative intent
very clearly was that these machines
would be
dispensers and the i am
offended by the fact that the lottery
commission
on changed them over to non-dispensers
already and that this the sections one
and two are just
affirming in law of what they did by
themselves
thank you so the amendment language is
written
if you wanted to wait for a future time
or not
on you could just pull that out
but it is connected at the moment with
repealing
sections one and two thank you had you
had an amendment drawn up for that yes i
told you that
uh i can i'm
sorry i i did it a couple of weeks ago
and then i forgot about it
so i can i could share it on the screen
if i was able to but i could also read
it to you
you muted yourself i
i pulled it up this morning on
but on i would need to
to stop being able to talk to you in
order
to to read it to you i think
or maybe i can just split my screen do
you want me to do that
let's try it it's the same language
tyler clark gave it
janine can she
share this these screens
norm i i actually have the language from
tyler
if if that would make it quicker for me
to read it
why don't you susan if she if she um
not hearing you susan
okay um oh dear if
um when four can give you the share
screen
access or patrick can read it
permissions are there permissions are
there okay
so you want to bring it up
on can i do that at this point share
screen
yes
oh no that's not it
would it help with representative romney
here i found it
um i thought i found it
that scroll there let's scroll up a
little bit you're there
yeah get this thing out of the way
there we go
can everyone else see it i can see it
authors can see it too so
tell us essentially what it does now
yeah
on all it does is it says
uh the existing current language is that
on the
tickets shall either be
50 cents or oh dear
i can't see it well enough because this
thing is on here
get myself out of there okay
uh shall be either 50 cents or
one dollar on it was
amended in the bill to say
as i recall 25 cents
the bill says 25 on
shall not exceed one dollar
on but where tickets where a charitable
organization offers one dollar tickets
for sale the charitable organization so
often
also offer 25 and 50 cent tickets for
sale
and that's the problem um so this one
says that the price shall not exceed one
dollar so it could be
25 cents uh providing that where
one dollar tickets are for sale the
charitable organization shall also
offer 50 tickets for sale which then
makes the 25 cents
possible but optional it would also make
one cent
possible but optional
what tyler clark said was that very
uh there are some organizations that
use the 25 cent ticket but very few of
them and the other ones are required to
buy it even though they aren't going to
use it
so your amendment eliminates one
and two yes that's the problem
you saw the problem from my point of
view it's a problem for most people's
point of view
you want to make a motion on your
amendment
on no because i know it's going to lose
okay mr chair can you speak
your amendment is not to be considered
anymore then it's not going to make a
motion
we could put
take a stroll vote on the
section that i just read without the
rest of it
and then on come back
when we do sp3 and do this one
i don't know what it advances us to
finish this bill now
mr chair can i speak representative
romney
yes i uh you know i reread the language
and i was a little confused but the way
it's
it's being uh discussed now
it actually makes some sense so i have
no problem with
us uh delaying this this vote
and uh waiting for next week or the
following week to executives bill
um with just the this amendment for the
to the
the third section of the bill only and
uh
so um and by the way
just we keep on talking about the the
charitable the charitable gaming
committee
i just double checked that committee
goes until 22.
so it's more than a year committee it's
uh like a year and a half committee so
uh there's certain things here that we
don't want to delay that long
but uh so but i i would suggest i
i would agree with representative valmie
that we we delay the vote on this
and that we uh if she wants to do that
amendment or
i can do it we can we can
have this amendment uh to fix this
language
and uh and then move forward um
you know in a week or two representative
uh
dessert yeah just to speak to that just
to be clear
um i i also agree with with
representatives component but we are
going to address in the amendment uh
the language for the deal size correct
we're gonna keep that included in asia
all we're doing is amending
all we're doing is amending section
three of the bill
so so in in that in that vein i'd
uh withdraw my motion if that's
appropriate
withdraw a second
representative bernstein
yes of course i'll withdraw my second
okay then
we will hold off executing
senate bill 22
the amendment
relative to the 25 cent ticket
will be addressed at the next time we
meet which will be next
tuesday when we discuss
senate bill 3.
uh mr chairman i would be perfectly
happy if representative abrami wants to
just take
my amendment and redo it
representative romney okay no problem
i'll do it
okay and you'll draw up the amendment
for
distributing to the committee members
prior to us
meeting next tuesday yep i'll let all
us know that that's the that's the
target okay
thank you and we will
hold off exactly that until next week
next is senate bill
27 senate bill 27
an act relative to the sale of lucky
seven tickets
and uh representative brownlee yes thank
you mr chairman
i make a motion uh to
want to pass on senate bill 27.
representative romney makes a motion out
to pass on senate bill 20 seconds
27 seconded by
i'll second it mr chairman
representative rehearsal
a newness
mr mr chair uh i think it's appropriate
now to move an amendment to this
representative romney
my amendment my move amendment 1236
h
which i think was handed out to the
committee a week or so ago
representatives you want to second that
yes sir i'll second that okay the
amendment
so senate bill 27 which is amendment
1236h
representative brown you want to speak
to your amendment yes i do
thank you mr chair um you know the more
i look at this overall bill
it really is a housekeeping bill uh
with one change but i'll get back to
that when we talk about the bill itself
um uh but through our deliberations
uh charlie mcintyre asked that i uh file
this
amendment for situations in which
a charity charitable organization
doesn't fall into one of the
appropriate buckets uh to give some
latitude and we heard some testimony
from
lisa allen i think her name was on her
organization at a restaurant chain
that also has a charitable arm feed new
hampshire
and the way that what the amendment
basically does is it says
uh you know the exception is it can
be made by the executive director of the
lottery uh but the organization
had to be established with the
charitable trust unit of the attorney
general's office
and has been in existence for a period
of two years prior to the application
the charitable works of the organization
take place primarily in the state of new
hampshire
and see all charitable gaming revenue
raised by the organization shall be used
to benefit the state of new hampshire
and its residents
so i
there's some things i want to mention
but uh they're really on the bill part
of it
uh and that uh and maybe i'll say a bit
of it here
what what the original bill does is
it it for for both
charitable games of chance which is
terrible gaming
and for bingo and uh lucky seven
the build uh re-codifies the language
that already exists for the most part
and it makes the
makes the charitable uh gaming language
and the bingo language
identical okay
and in terms of the definition of what a
charitable organization
is and uh
and and i i i i want to get ahead of
myself in terms of talking about the
bill itself
uh but all this does is it gives
a little attitude for an exception
uh to be made as long as those three
criteria
are met uh by the uh by the organization
so that is basically the amendment
any further discussion on the amendment
saying then i'll ask the clerk to call
the vote on the amendment mr chairman
there are two people with their hands up
um okay i didn't see that representative
ames
i think representative schamberg had his
hand up before me
okay representative thank you mr
chairman mr representative
uh when you said the money shall be used
for the benefit of the
uh state and the citizens residents of
new hampshire
if an organization raises the money do
they have to expend it outside their
organization
or can they just spend it within their
organization for themselves
uh i i i think it's outside
it's raising money for their
organization most of these i mean we got
fraternal organizations
usually they exist to support uh
charities if you will uh uh
but again this this language is
consistent with
uh the way we're defining charitable
organizations
in general
yeah um
i guess just a couple of questions for
representative romney really
you've got in here first condition is
the organization has to be in existence
for a period of at least two years
right and the bill is
the reasons that i don't think i've ever
been fully explained moving
the existing two-year requirement down
to one year
so that would be one of the waivers it's
kind of a weird waiver it's increasing
the
restriction but um why
why the two years one year why any of
this
well that that's the you hit on one of
the changes of the bill
that from current law is moving the
the period the waiting period from uh
one uh from uh two years to one year
uh and uh
it was felt i guess by by lottery that
this this was a more appropriate
waiting period uh and i and then
my my thinking was that they kept it at
two years for the exception because it's
an
exception uh just to make it a little
more difficult
and give them more time to to evaluate
that charity okay
i can understand that the um
one of my difficulties with this is that
there were several quests
there were other questions that were
raised in the
when we were originally dealing with
this bill which we never got back to as
a
committee maybe it's my fault for not
raising them but
uh we never really had the kind of
review that
i think we used to do
another another issue is but i guess i'm
getting over onto that i'm getting over
under the bill itself and maybe i
shouldn't uh yeah i was going to respond
to the bill itself actually
yeah not to that um any further
questions on the amendment
i see no hands um then representative
bernstein you want to call the role
on the amendment sure this um roll call
vote is on amendment
1236 h to sb 27 we'll begin the roll
call vote with representative abrami
yes representative johnson
yes hillary yes
over yes set
yes bursting votes yes elliot
yes pimanti
representative pamanti you're muted
sorry about that yes representative
nunes
yes rooney yes
stillsbury guest tutor
yes how me yes
ames yes
southward yes
yes representative thomas c
schamberg representative schamberg votes
yes mr cork
tucker no
representative go marlow yes
laughman yes
gorg yes captain
yes murphy yes chairman major
yes mr chair of the amendment passes
23 to 1.
now we are on the bill as amended
any discussion yes i'd like to speak to
the uh
representative so uh
there's four parts of the bill the first
part
is something that we've already uh
within another bill that we already
voted
on so that is redundant but that'll be
handled by uh if passed it'll be
handled by the uh enrollment process
uh what it does is it it it it we really
recodifies
a bit the uh the definitions of what
charity is
and making the the the definition of a
charity
the same for games of chance as well as
for
uh bingo and unlucky seven so
what we got hung up on and i got hung up
on
was all those 501 c codes
and uh the more i studied this the last
couple of uh last week
it was clear it became clearer to me
that
we weren't creating these codes as new
these these codes already existed in the
current statute
uh first off and it's just been
rearranged
uh within the within the document
but the real definition of charitable
organization
is as it says means any bona fide
religious
charitable civic veterans or fraternal
or church organization
including police in firemen's
organizations
and houses of worship which shall have
been registered
with the secretary of state for at least
they used to say two years
and the change is made to one year and
then
it gives then you also have to meet the
one through four underneath it uh
and so you have to be you could be a
general organization
but you have to be you have to have a
document that your organization has a
tax-exempt status under the internal
revenue code
one of those you know six
six codes there in those six codes
are other things like we talked about in
in in committee
you know some of these may be uh
political organizations and things like
that
but that's that's what they did in the
original
when they created this original law is
they said well
we it has to be a charitable
organization and as above
but it has to be also registered with
the internally
revenue code as a non-uh tax-exempt
as long as it falls under one of those
codes so
uh we're not creating anything new here
i mean this has always been the way
it has been although i i take that back
it's that it always was that way in the
bingo
lucky seven language but now they're
putting that same language to make the
two languages the same
they're putting it into the charitable
uh
organization the game's chance statutes
so that's really the the big change and
that to me is a housekeeping thing that
was done uh with the exception of
changing it to one year
uh from the two and then uh the the
the uh third thing it did was uh
uh i guess in the fourth paragraph on
page two
it it it was a uh everywhere where there
was a
reference to lottery they changed the
word to commission
because that was misused if you recall i
think we discussed
this last year and it wasn't another
bill that didn't make it through the
process
it's a the commission is actually
commissioned meaning
the the winnings the commission that the
organization got
not the lottery so so wherever you see
lottery commission
they they changed it to just they took
out lottery and it was
just uh commission and then the
the final uh the final change
was in the definition of a deal with
lucky seven
and it just says deal means a single
game of
uncirculated lucky seven tickets bearing
a serial number
so those were the four things that the
bill did uh i would i would
i would argue that most of these are
housekeeping
uh and uh that's why i
i don't think we should wait for
our commission to be done uh which would
be
you know not until november of 22
so probably a year and a half away so
that's why i
i thought it was wise to just move
forward with this and
doesn't mean we can't discuss some of
these things in the commission
but i think we should just move forward
with it
thank you representative ames followed
by representative
almy and yuri represent ames
you admitted
okay i'll begin again um sorry about
that
and thank you uh to representative
romney for
all the work that has gone into this um
i i basically agree i agree
that we can go forward with this
i think the uh the biggest issue
that's uh that needs further work is
is the question of what is a charitable
organization what's the definition going
to be
and i think that
that can be probed and worked on
by the commission that we all hope will
be established
or it's a committee isn't it joint
committee yes
yeah committee um and
uh that uh
hopefully hopefully that committee will
[Music]
bring things together and deal with this
string of irc
internal revenue code sections in a
coherent way
that makes sense and make sure that that
listing those
makes sense for our purposes um
and uh and then there were other issues
that i remember raising
when we started our look at this bill
maintaining a current list of bona fide
members is a requirement
is that an appropriate requirement
[Music]
i i'm not sure but it's i think it's
nothing new and we need to
look at that and i hopefully this
committee will look at that among other
larger issues too that that committee
will look at
so i guess i'm all of that is to say
um say okay for this
looking at this as a
consolidation of bringing together
concepts
between all games of chance and bingo
and lucky seven
um so that's it okay uh representative
alame
followed by representing earlier thank
you mr chair
on
i think that there was there seemed to
be a major problem
which is being uh in for not being
enforced
about maintain a current list of bona
fide members for a number of charities
but on i
basically we have not done
a thorough re-examination of charitable
gaming regulation
since it was started on
and when it was started it did not
include
machine gaming machine gaming is a lot
more addictive
our regulation seems to consist only of
financial
that is financial of the gaming
organization
itself so that the state and the
charities get their money
on it does not include the problem of
the addiction part of charitable gaming
as it is now called in this state uh
everywhere else it's called casino
gaming
and there's a lot more regulation and it
provides a lot more money to the state
on and um
it's a very different bowl of wax than
what on
the we've got regulations for and
so i am opposed to this
bill passing uh
especially until there is an
actual study of uh what needs to be done
for regulation charitable gaming we
don't
even know if all the parts
of this i presume that all the parts of
this
are going to be on
enforced in some way by the lottery
commission
but the parts of it that have to do with
on where the money
is actually going uh
is something that has to be looked at by
that commission
uh who who is deciding where
where the money goes the the one that we
just
the amendment that we just passed could
allow for some major difficulties
since the attorney general's office
can't do proper oversight
um in terms of burger king
setting up such a organization and
on sending the money only to its
own subsidiaries in some way so
but on that's true also of a lot of
other
of these groups once once
now we have two forms of scene gaming
that are very close to slot machines
that are going to be all over the state
and
we're getting almost no money from them
and they are
unregulated except for the financial
flow and
that's that is my real
worry that we are not being serious
about
regulation of something the other states
regulate
thank you thank you representative
thank you mr chair uh the comments that
uh
representative ames made regarding uh
following the irc
and is is
is accurate regarding
the interface however that is something
that requires a committee to study
as representative only pointed out
this particular amendment this
particular bill
are immaterial to that
as the gaming is going on right now
and for the most part it's going
for charitable items i can think of
several
uh hundreds of thousands of dollars that
are going to
uh disabled individuals that are going
to the
nephrology clinic up in uh dartmouth by
the knights of columbus
uh uh the uh lions club doing uh
blind assistance uh the masons doing uh
their thing each one of the various
fraternities has the things into
uh in danger or to restrict
their ability to continue to raise funds
for these charitable items
at this point in time would seem to be
disadvantageous to the population of new
hampshire
at the same time what representative
omni speaks of
our review and a discussion and
development is something that the
commission
hopefully will be set up to do and i
would urge this committee
to set up an ad hoc committee if the
commission doesn't go forward
uh to discuss this uh further to make
sure that the
structure of the gaming is done by
a separate entity affiliated with in
some fashion
so that we do know where the money is
going and when they hold a uh
charitable poker night at the uh at the
river or
at seabrook uh you know where the money
is going
in the same way that you would if you
were doing a lottery or a
raffle excuse me uh those are all my
only comments i support the bill
as amended thank you representative
romney
you muted that
yeah my wife came into the room to pick
something off the printer and i
well the printer started printing so i
had to mute myself so
uh remember our house bill
565 we passed unanimous to former
commission it was representative ames
bill
uh that moved on it passed on consent
calendar went over to the senate of the
past
unanimous but they put it on the table
as i told you everyone last week i spoke
to
i reached out to senator d'alessandro
and we agreed
uh he even suggested that we broaden
ours
our membership to four and uh we
discussed this last week
and we're we're doing it in a very
bipartisan way we're going to have two
two for the majority party and two from
the minority party
from the house side and there's going to
be one from the senate
uh uh finance committee and one from the
senate ways and means committee
so he and i this morning just uh
testified before leggy administration
where
there's an omnibus bill senate bill 100
and this was part four
and the chair allowed me and senator
alessandro to speak first on
section four and we agreed you know you
know
we're good uh so i think this is
definitely going to pass
the senate bill uh 100 part four at the
very least is going to pass
and we're on our way with
two members of the senate and four
members of the house uh
to to look at this and we all agree we
it's time
we can't say we haven't looked at this
in the last since the beginning of time
i was on a commission uh it was more
than a committee it was a commission
with state police we had uh you know all
sorts of people on it
uh and uh and
uh i think we got a good group uh we'll
have six members
and we can take a thorough look at this
all the things that we've been discussed
today
thank you
representing ames
thank you um i just wanted to say thank
you
uh patrick representative romney that's
a
good report and uh it gives me uh
even more encouragement to go ahead with
this
this this bill knowing that
more work is going to be done so thank
you thank you
any further discussion on senate bill 27
motion about to pass with amendment
sam and representative bernstein would
you call the vote
thank you mr chair let's begin the roll
call vote on
sb 27 the motion is ought to pass
with amendment the amendment is 1236
h representative abrami yes
representative johnson yes
yes over yes you set
yes pardon me the clerk votes yes
elliot
representative elliott
representative elliot
representative elliot uh please cast
your vote on sb
27 the motion is otp as amended
unmute yourself
yourself bob yes
thank you sir representative pimanti
yes nunes yes mooney
yes billsbury yes
tudor yes almi
no ames yes
southward yes malloy
yes representative thomas c schaumburger
john representative schamberg both yes
mr burnstein
representative tucker yes go marlon
yes laughman yes
gorg yes hacking phillips
yes murphy
yes chairman major yes
mr chair of the motion of otp as amended
passes
23 to 1. is there any objection
put on consent
i think i want to write a blurb thank
you
okay it will go on regular calendar
next we're going to take up another
name a chance bill which is senate bill
139-fn
relative to bingo dates
representative representative tudor
moves to retain
hb 139 representative
tudor moves to retain hp
i mean senate bill 139 i'm sorry senate
bill
senator seconded by no second
president representative
representative you want to speak yes
thank you mr chair
uh some of the committee members felt
that the bill might have unintended
consequences and
and wanted the study committee once it's
formed
to look at it and advise the committee
on on how to how it was the best way to
proceed with this bill
so we wanted to move to retain it
any further discussion on the motion to
retain
senate bill 139
further discussion on senate bill 139
stan and representative bernstein you
want to
take the vote on retaining senate bill
sure let's begin the vote with
representative abrami
yes uh representative johnson
yes hillary yes
ober no ducette
yes the clerk votes yes
representative ellie yes pimanti
yes nunes yes
mooney yes pillsbury
yes tudor yes
army yes
ames yes
southward yes malloy
yes representative thomas c schamberg
rep chamber of votes yes mr clerk
thank you sir represent my pardon me
representative tucker
yes go marlow yes laughman
yes gorg yes
hakken phillips yes murphy
yes chairman major yes
mr chair the motion to retain sb 139
carries by a vote of 23 to 1.
we shall retain senate bill 139 name
committee
next is executive session on senate bill
101-fn
increase in the minimum gross business
income required for
filing a business profits tax return
representative jordan yearly
representative yearly yeah i had to find
the thing here
excuse me um yeah i move out to pass
and i have an amendment to offer um that
representative almighty put together
thank you
before we do that uh representative
yearly
moves out to pass representative elmy do
you second that
yes representative me seconds
representatively yeah i would move uh
unauthorized amendment uh 2021
1 3 6 7 h
which was mailed out by representative
almi yesterday
unfortunately i was in the senate while
she was doing the stuff would work out
basically what this amendment does is
increases the
hold on right erupting nearly
moves out to pass on
amendment 1367h and second
by representing elmi yes
second by right representative elmi go
ahead
uh representing your leader after some
confusion
uh with ols and
dra we got it together and the right
dates are in the right place
uh basically what this does is has
language
that allows for the um
i can't think of the word here uh limit
it in a bi-annual manner of the uh
uh filing threshold starting with 92 000
and then working forward from there uh
with an applicable date of december 31st
2020 the act takes effect
january july 1st 2021 and
for the tax years beginning january 1st
the governor sets up uh the
adjustment uh based upon the previous
two year period
from the consumer price index for the
northeast region
i think i've said it right danny for the
discussion
representative alani thank you mr
chairman
on i'd just like to point the fiscal
note for
92 000 is 2.6 million dollars
a year on which is about a million more
than what the original bill was
but it does bring us up on i asked
dra to calculate on
where we would be with inflation from
when
the last threshold was set uh
and it is about a hundred dollars off i
think
from 92 92
uh uh thousand
uh as a threshold so we are about as
close as
you can get and from there we'd keep up
with whatever inflation sends us
on so that we wouldn't have uh
smaller businesses being uh
uplifted into paying bpt
when in fact they aren't getting any
more real money
than they were getting before and we
also
won't have a shock uh even of
2.5 million 2.6 million
uh this year i think our shock for bet
was greater at the time
to on to our revenues we will gradually
adapt to it
so um i hope that
everybody will vote for this thank you
any further discussion on the amendment
saying none uh representative bernstein
called the
vote on the amendment
the motions will ought to pass
thank you mr chair uh this is for
amendment 1367
h we'll begin the roll call vote with
representative abrami yesterday
johnson yes over
uh yes
over yes ducette
yes the clerk votes yes representative
elliott
yes pimanti yes nunes
yes mooney yes billsbury
yes tudor yes
representative army yes ames
yes southworth yes malloy
yes representative thomas c schamberg
representative schamberg votes
yes mr corker thank you sir
representative tucker
yes go marlo yes laughman
yes gorg yes hacking phillips
yes murphy yes
chairman major yes good job everyone
mr chair the vote is 24 to nothing the
amendment
carries mr chair uh who sends this over
do i send this over to ols to get the
little
impremature stamp on it
right that'll happen after we
take the vote on the bill
thank you
now the motion on the floor
is ought to pass on senate bill 101
with amendment 1367
h further discussion
any further discussion on senate bill
as amended
sam nunn and representative bernstein
would you call the vote
thank you mr chair i'll remind everyone
just to hover over that mute button
the unmute button we'll begin the roll
call vote on sb 101 as amended with
representative obrani
yes representative johnson yes
owerry yes ober yes
yes the clerk votes yes representative
elliot
yes pimanti yes nunes
yes mooney yes spillsbury
yes tudor yes
aumi
ames yes southward
yes malloy yes representative thomas c
schamberg representative schamberg is
hovering
yes representative tucker
yes go marlow yes laughman
yes gorg yes
hacken phillips yes murphy
yes chairman major yes mr chair the
motion
carries 24 to nothing
the motion about to pass as amended 24
or nothing
without objection will go on consent any
objection
mr chairman things that cost
or save money have to go
on regular calendar
good question i don't remember
i think they do so then why don't we
just put on the regular calendar
thank you representative
now we're going to executive session on
senate bill
103-fn relative to nexus provision
for certain disaster related or
emergency related
work performed in the state
representative bernstein
i'd like to move otp on sb 103
representative bernstein moves o2 otp on
103. do we have a second
a second representing all me seconds
representative bernstein you want to
speak to your motion
thank you mr chair this bill waives
certain business registration
licensing and taxation requirements for
out-of-state businesses performing work
in new hampshire
during a declared state of emergency
this narrowly targeted bill
will permit out-of-state businesses to
focus on emergency restoration of
critical utility
and communications services during a
declared state of emergency
passage of this bill will enable new
hampshire to join at least 32 other
states including maine vermont and
connecticut
to streamline emergency infrastructure
restoration
by allowing out-of-state businesses to
bypass onerous
licensing and registration requirements
so they may restore vital services
as rapidly as possible
thank you representative romney
thank you mr chair uh
the only the only discussion we had on
this bill and the work session
uh really was on the notification
paragraph
on the second page uh
where it says the that the
uh any out of state business that is
present in the state of
uh or conducts operations in the state
to perform disaster related or emergency
related work
during the disaster response period
shall provide
upon request of the secretary of state a
written statement that such business
is in the state for purpose of
responding to a state of disaster or
emergency
and the question became well how does
the secretary of state know they're here
so i think i said to the committee that
i would reach out to the prime sponsor
and then
actually to the secretary of state's
office which i did i talked to
senator bradley who said he he didn't
he didn't view this as a problem uh he
directed me to uh
maura weston who's uh lobbyist
for i think a t who reminded me pat this
is
just for telecom companies
and for utilities and we have a limited
number of both
in this state so we know who they are so
then i i called
david scanlan at the secretary of
state's office who's basically number
two over there i think most of you know
that
uh and i read the paragraph to him he
says i'm aware of it
he says we don't we don't have a problem
with the language
uh we we know if there's a true state of
emergency called
we will know who to go to to to make
sure they they uh
let us know they're in the state so
that was the response i got from the
secretary of state's office just wanted
to pass that along
so i definitely support the bill too so
thank you
any further discussion on senate bill
103.
saying representative bernstein you want
to call the vote
on senate bill 103-fn
thank you mr chair we will begin the
roll call vote on sb 103
with representative abrami yes
representative johnson yes
ovary yes over yes
you said yes the clerk votes yes
representative elliott yes pimanti
yes nunes yes
mooney yes spillsbury
yes tudor yes
army yes ames
yes southward yes malloy
yes the honorable representative thomas
jamberg representative bernstein you
read that very well
i vote yes thank you sir representative
tucker
yes yo marlon yes
laughman yes gourd
yes hacking phillips yes
murphy yes chairman major
yes mr chair of the motion or
of ought to pass carries 24 to nothing
we've been 24 or nothing motion
passes uh any objection
go on consent calendar
i see no objection so it will go on the
consent calendar
now we've come out of executive session
anybody that mr chairman
you have sb-112
that's right we are still in an
executive session
sp 112. um
which is relative to historic racing
representative romney
chair i make a motion to retain senate
bill 112.
representative romney makes a motion to
retain
senate bill 112 representative schamberg
seconds
and representatives
representative real quick uh as we know
that this is this bill is identical to
house bill 626 that
uh passed uh passed the house and the
senate so
what the reason to retain is just in
case something goes off the tracks
between now and the governor signing it
i i i
would appreciate a fallback position by
keeping this alive thank you
in addition to van in those two places
essentially this bill is in the
budget that we had passed
any further discussion on senate bill
112 motion retained
no discussion representative bernstein
you want to call the
vote thank you mr chair we will begin
the
roll call vote on sb 112 the motion is
to retain
let's start with representative pat
abrami yes
johnson yes hillary yes
over yes
uh doucet yes the clerk votes yes
elliot yes pimanti yes
nunes yes mooney
yes spillsbury yes
tudor yes army
yes ames yes southward
yes malloy yes representative thomas c
schamberg representative schamberg votes
yes mr cork
thank you sir representative tucker yes
so marla yes laughman
yes gordon yes hacken phillips
yes murphy yes chairman major
yes mr chair the motion to retain sb
112 passes 24 to nothing
for the motion to retain passing 24 or
nothing
senate bill 112 will be retained in
committee
now we are out of
executive session where we have left
for um
bills senate bill
22 which representative romney is going
to
provide an amendment for and senate bill
3 which has to do
with the ppp loans
then
exempt from tax
does anybody have anything they want to
add to what we
know about senate bill 3 at this point
in time
i'm having the dira come in tomorrow
to further try to clarify
the revenues that we have that's above
plan by an amount
and trying to segregate it into two
pieces
one piece that has to do with
senate bill 3 passes how much of this
is associated with that 174 we already
have there
and how much will have to be refunded
and another peak we've asked them to
look at
is that there's been a number of
stimulus packages since the pandemic
started
that have been applied to our state
which
affects revenues it keeps people
employed uh and that
and therefore it generates a profit that
would not have happened
and we need to understand about how much
of that
excess that we have right now is
associated with that
because that's more of a one-time event
even though it may be spread out over a
few years
once the pandemic is over and we're back
to normal
that is not going to be with us
and so they need to understand
that there's a certain amount of that
excess that we have
is associated with one-time money
and a certain amount that's associated
with money that would
we will have to refund the senate bill
3 passes as is so
um we need we will be provided more
information tomorrow
on that
any further questions
representative romney followed by
representative
and representative tucker so
i got a couple of emails yesterday i
guess we all did that
it sounds like chairman yellen
uh the treasury has come out with some
guidance um
and i haven't had a chance to read it
yet um but
that's a that's a factor in this whole
discussion that
yes whether or not uh they will uh
if we pass recipe if we pass sb3
whether the uh forgiveness of the
grant's uh
which would now then be non-taxable if
we pass sp3
if we can use some of the whatever that
i lose track of the names of these
the 1.9 trillion dollar bill rescue
plan thank you uh whether we can use
that to offset
this uh loss in uh revenue
so that that's a factor that we i think
that was the last piece that we're
waiting
to hear about so but i don't know any
more detail i haven't read it yet so
and maybe someone else has and the only
other thing while i'm on
representative army can you can you help
me out and
give me the amendment number later on uh
sb 22 that you had
so like when i referred to all os
i can send it to you yeah that'd be
great thank you i thought i'd send it to
everyone back then but
i may not have okay thank you
and um i downloaded what i could
about what just came out yesterday on
that on american rescue plan
but we really need to have somebody that
understands this
come before the committee so that we can
ask them get a feeling what we can
and what we can't do with this money
and so i'm trying to work that out so
that
somebody such as who we had before can
come
and make that presentation to the
committee
represented elmi
and then tucker thank you mr chairman
on i did manage to listen into that
last night i had to beg off of something
i promised to do
and neither the presentation
nor the document that they sent out with
it
had enough specifics to answer any of
the questions that we have
they did not mention the ppp loans in
the
the document or the presentation on
and i think that um well and
and there are there's some stuff
that i consider rather worrisome about
your tax cuts
on that on the the way
they seem to be defining economic growth
so it's defined
in another section then the one
specifically about
tax cuts on is
that on that
it would you would have to have had a
a revenue loss of a certain amount
i think through this year i can't quite
remember i read it yet
last night for the first time um but
um i i do have a link
and uh everybody should have the link
soon
of on the to ask
specific questions of the man that has
been put in charge of the recovery unit
in the treasury
on i don't know how long it's going to
take him to ask questions that come
from a specific uh
state about our specific issues
but i uh wanted to
uh mention that here today before trying
to use the link to say
did you forget to talk about ppp and
is that thing we got last week
still still valid which would mean that
we could recover
that particular money from them but i am
not sure whether we could recover all of
it because
our loss will will come
over four years i think you said earlier
today
and dra will be talking to us about
tomorrow
and um they may only
allow recovery for for three years or
two
so on we need to get that kind of thing
specified i don't think
anybody except treasury is going to be
able to specify it for us
but we do have a way that we can ask
them
this is why the dra will be here
tomorrow to help
clarify some of these questions that we
will need to
ask treasury or somebody representing
treasury
but dra needs to get their act together
in which they have
which they're working on
because i was surprised
they could tell me that
the ppp loans so there's a certain
percentage that
will be affected this year
next year and and the bulk will be the
next two years
in a trivial amount the fourth year
um representative tucker followed by
representatives
yeah i i would like to tomorrow
have someone go over what the people who
got these loans what
what did they think were the controlling
factors
on whether they'd ever have to pay taxes
or not
i'd sort of like to focus on that at the
outset
because that's what people are talking
about and
it's clear that ways and means has to
think about a bigger picture
but i am very interested in what
individuals
citizens of new hampshire thought when
they
cashed their checks what did they
think were the rules
and why did they think that i'd like to
go over that
because we've done a lot of talking and
i still would like to know the answer to
that
i think we all would thank you
representatives
yeah thank you um
[Music]
yeah i i have uh looked at the document
sent out by the treasury i've read some
of them
the key document that has the detail in
it is
what they call their interim final rule
it's basically a published
ruling on uh implementation
of this act the american rescue plan
act and it has detailed provisions in it
that relate to what
in shorthand are called tax cuts
[Music]
and you can find it easily just by
searching for our um
rp um interim final rule
and you'll get it it's uh i i warn you
it's 160 page document
um so a couple of things
that are relevant to sp3 and then
more broadly the sp3 relevance is
what's had been mentioned the conformity
issue
um if if new hampshire conforms
um in effect it's a tax cut
conforms to the rp rule that doesn't
that excuses from taxation the ppp
loan forgiveness forgiveness
new hampshire's decision to conform
quite clearly they said this before
in a statement earlier
but the is in this interim final rule
quite clearly would not
be counted against new hampshire as a
tax cut
that's my reading i assume it will be
dra's reading
i think it's clear and
it's somewhere around page 86 i
seem to have misplaced my my print out
of this
but about page 86 of that interim final
rule
um then going beyond that
i think what's really important to for
ways and means to get an understanding
of
is the ongoing process that
treasury will use to assess
whether new hampshire
in adopting one or another
tax cut
trespasses on the standard that
treasury will apply in determining
whether there will be some clawback if
you will
of um of rp revenues
that and there's a lot of language in
there
about how
how the federal government will
do that assessment um and
a lot of it involves the kind of work
that ways and means is very much into
which is estimating revenues associated
with this that or the other
tax decision
so we've got to figure out our a number
of things but one
one is exactly what's expected of the
state
and the second one is what role
the legislature and ways and means
should play with respect
to these judgments and my understanding
again this was a quick reading of it is
that it's a year
to year process
so um there
it's a repetitive reiterative kind of
thing
looking at performance they try to
try to allow for a full discount of
revenue gains or losses that are related
to economic conditions that
have nothing to do with or maybe
indirectly very indirectly
relate to the stimulus of the federal
money but that are not directly related
to
to the provisions of rb and its grant
money
so we've got to be sure that we
understand what's expected of us
and that we're doing what we should be
doing as a legislative body
i think that's pretty important and then
there are
just a note there are what you might
call
safe harbors there there are rules of
thumb
that the federal government will apply
a standard inflation factor that would
be presumptive for
each state that if revenue came in above
revenue from the sort of general fund
education
trust fund kinds of uh money that we
have
um came in above
uh or below estimated money there would
be this sort of test that would be
applied and
if you were in the right place relative
to that
test there would be no further inquiry
it's sort of a safe harbor
um and it's really complicated so i'm
not sure i'm fully
i'm explaining it exactly right but
anyway there's a lot of work to be done
here
and hopefully dra will help us
work through that uh including telling
us who
and on the executive side will be
working on these issues so
that's it thank you before i go to
represent elmi
in addition the american recovery act
affects funds that are going to go
directly to the
local community your local
county and the state
so we need to understand as legislators
especially with our county
because we all set the county budget
what we can
and what we can't do with these funds as
well as what we can and can
do for the state and we need to help
the our community that we live in
understand what they can and can't do
so we've got a lot of work ahead of us
because of this
representative elmi thank you
i got a couple of things now on
taking the last first on
what they sent us that i can send
send everybody on was
a synthesis document of what
representative ames was just talking
about plus a lot more including and they
were more interested
in talking to municipal and county
heads than they were in talking to a
state in that
this in that meeting that i listened to
last night
on so that you could start from that
synthesis
and then go to the 165 page document to
search for county
for instance and find a lot of the
material
what i'm really most worried about on
on the tax cut side is
what um is the timing of
when what period they
they mean and maybe they were more
specific in the 165 pager
on what time period they meant when they
said growth from what
time because we got a lot of money in
just now
the year 19 is the standard it's the
year 19 but
who's fiscal year
that's what on on
and they they yeah they did say fiscal
year once but
they didn't say whether it was state or
or federal
um and there's a big difference there
so um that needs to be cleared up
and how long they would
allow us to be whether
if we recalculate year to year then
since we lost money in 20 if we weren't
able to re
re recover in
21 could we recover that
in 22 um
these are all things these are all
things we we need to
to get straight and once we understand
what the rules are
right well on yeah and that's where i
hope dra can
can help us with that if not we're going
to you're going to have to be
asking a set of specific questions to
the treasury
there's an only dra we need to get some
expertise here that can
any questions that we have of the
treasury
yeah but i don't think we're going to
get a person from the treasury
to our committee so
and i think we have specific questions
based on new hampshire's
tax system so i think we may have to
depend on you sending a list of formal
questions and seeing
how soon we can get the answers back but
um the or dra sending it
on the other thing was that we could
try to invite a chamber head
or two to to talk to us about
ed's question represent tucker's
question
about uh what the applicants for ppp
thought they were getting into when they
when they got
the loans that they were planning on
getting forgiven
and on that
on we've got some chamber links that we
could call on
i know the the one in the upper valley
has been
very strong in in helping
businesses in our region to to apply for
these
and work their way through them and i
presume
that's true also in nashua and
probably in a number of they have all
been talking to each other so probably
any of the chamber heads could could
talk to us about
what that was right we need to
understand those things but number one
the most important is the rules
and how how we can utilize these without
having to pay money back so we
channel it in the right once we
understand that
then we can address what people think
and other things and what and what we
can
and can't do
mr chairman a deserved time frame for
this
the 27th or because
i think it is unfortunately
uh we need to address senate bill 3
and we need to have it out by
i'm already sent
around the 20s so that's one issue
the other issue is to understand
the rules on the american recovery funds
and once we understand that we'll
probably understand the rules on the
other side
and so the sooner we can do that and
hopefully we can understand it before we
pass a budget
because if we pass
and as you say if we pass a budget
that cuts some taxes
we may be foolish
because we may lose more money
we may want to delay some of those
things
so that we don't it doesn't
interfere with the rules for utilizing
the american recovery funds and the
others so we have to understand those
things
we don't know that yet we need guys like
represent ames and and the smart people
that we have on
our committee plus more to ask
these questions and get answers
all right anything else uh
representative software
uh thank you just briefly for dover
um it's been fairly consistent that
people have said
they were hoping the loans would be
forgiven um
but on the other hand especially the
larger businesses
paid the estimated tax as if they were
going to have to pay
so they kind of you know have looked at
both sides and i have a feeling that's
probably fairly consistent
yeah and so they contributed to
this bump that we had in
business taxes that we see now
that uh if this passes as
is we're going to have to refund
it would seem that way yes okay
anybody else comments
representative or you have another
comment
you're muted
i just got completely muted uh i didn't
really mean to hit it anyway but
i think that uh we've got a pretty clear
idea from
the local cpas that
on the local businesses
pretty much all if they had enough
profit
to worry about it took that option
that on representative southworth is
talking about
my problem is how many of the
subsidiaries
of the megacorporations that pay most of
our tax
on took that and were incorporated
into the water's edge filing
and how much wood might we lose from
that and did dr was dra thinking of that
problem
tomorrow you'll have an opportunity to
bring that question up again to the dra
thanks
any other comments before we break
so what time do we start tomorrow
tomorrow at 10 o'clock
thank you anything else
anybody well
mr chairman yes on how long do i have to
write a blurb
minority one
i i since it's going to be a while
if we have all the blurbs in by
thursday next week that would be fine
thank you
okay then
we'll break until tomorrow at 10 o'clock
and thank you everybody yeah
[Music]
you